6 15 here on a monday morning all right
let's switch gears and talk about hockey
who's ready for some nhl action
hopefully the answer to that question is
the vegas golden knights alex yeah we're
all ready for it they start their
training camp today ahead of their
fourth nhl season our bianca holman live
at city national where the players will
hit the ice
in just a few hours hey bianca this is
so exciting
hey alex hey john yeah this is so
exciting it's always exciting when we
talk about the vegas golden knights
and yeah their practice and training
camp starts
today but unlike in past years where
it's been open to the public
nobody from the outside no public can
attend these training camp games
so a lot has changed this year as things
get started
and so training camp it usually starts
in july but of course it was delayed
because of the pandemic
last season just wrapped up at the end
of september
this year will look a lot different each
team will play 56 games instead of 82
unlike last season which they finished
in two bubble cities
teams will travel but that's limited
regionally
meaning the knights will only play seven
of the league's 30
teams they'll play two games per trip in
each city
for further reduced travel the night
general manager says the shortened
schedule
had a lot of upsides but unlike it'll be
like
nothing they've ever done before it's
going to be a sprint we're
you know effectively beginning in the
second half of the season right now in a
lot of respects so there's going to be a
lot of hockey
and it's important to be to be ready to
be prepared and that's what training
camp
will do for our teams
with training camps starting today the
golden knights don't have a lot of time
to get ready they won't have any
preseason games before the season starts
next thursday january 14 at home against
the anaheim ducks
and there won't be any fans allowed at
the games at least for the start of the
season so far so
coming up in the next half hour we're
going to talk about some of those
continued changes that the nhl has
established for
this season reporting live from city
national arena bianca holman 8 news now
yeah it's unfortunate we're not going to
get to see the games in the at least the
immediate
bianca but it'll be good to see them
back in action nonetheless
all right thank you sir or ma'am i
should say 617 staff at t-mobile arena
meanwhile they're getting the ice
ready for the upcoming season the
fortress hasn't hosted a game for the
golden knights
since the pandemic began back in march
the rest of the nhl season as bianca
mentioned was played in those two bubble
cities
up in canada so not just the golden
knights guys but
the rest of the league also getting
ready for the shortened
nhl season normally we'd be what halfway
through essentially
the uh nhl season but now we're just
kind of getting going alex
so it'll be short but i think because
they're going to be playing all the same
teams for those 56 games
there's going to be some good animosity
some good hatred and some good rivalries
developing it'll be great
yeah yeah thank you ma'am it'll be a
good season
we're so excited i'm excited to see
those players back on the ice too it's
been a while nate